i don't even really know how to start
today other than to tell you
that it's okay to say that donald trump
is racist that's really something we
need to talk about today
it has to be discussed in order to take
power back from the right on this issue
because the right has waged a really
effective war
against saying people are racist they've
done this for years
actually and the reason is clear there's
a ton of racism on the right explicit
and
implicit if they can stigmatize
the calling out of racism the saying
that someone is racist they are mostly
helping themselves this doesn't mean
racism and xenophobia don't exist on the
left
i've talked about anti-semitism on the
left but as a political
strategy this is something that
disproportionately benefits the right
the being able to say
you're calling someone a racist that's
the problem and they've used a few
strategies in order to do this
one literally can't be refuted
when they say racism is what's deep in
someone's mind or
heart and no matter what somebody says
you don't really know whether deep down
they are racist in their hearts and
minds so you shouldn't call anyone a
racist because no matter what it seems
as though they believe
you don't really know deep down in their
heart of hearts what they believe
this is a joke because it's completely
unfalsifiable
it's it's possible that someone is
acting like a racist
and saying racist things and suggesting
racist
policy but that they're merely acting
and that deep down
they don't actually believe any of those
things but that's the same way that
you can't know for sure if someone is a
narcissist from their media presence
because they could be acting
but think about donald trump we have
decades of donald trump's interviews and
actions if your argument
is he's only been acting like a
narcissist for 40 years
and we can't possibly know whether he
actually is one
it's a really weak argument because we
could never really know one way or
another even if we ask trump
hey listen you've said and done all
these things it seems like you're a
narcissist
but deep down are you really whatever
his answer is could also be a lie so
that is just a dead end path
to really figure out whether someone is
x y or z but the more important thing
is that when we're talking about public
figures
that dictate policy in particular
what matters is what they say and do
publicly
in the sense that if i'm not personally
racist but i run a campaign on racist
ideas and coalesce racist voters around
me
and i have xenophobic and racist ideas
about crime
and iq and cleanliness and whatever
what difference does it make if
somewhere deep down
in secret in my house at night i'm not
actually racist my public persona is a
racist one and that is what is important
and media
have fallen for this media are often
afraid to call people racists or
xenophobes because republicans have
really successfully run this campaign
of criticizing those who spot racism and
xenophobia
now another strategy is they say well
you're
actually the racist for seeing race
in this issue you are seeing race in
what someone said
when it didn't have to be that way you
must be the one who is racist
identifying racism and calling it out
is the real racism this is the second
strategy that that strategy that the
right has employed
in order to try to insulate themselves
from their racism and xenophobia
it's another failed laughable argument
it's like the childish
whoever smelt it dealt it thing about
farting i mean
literally saying if you believe there is
racism
and if you see race you are the racist
is like
in the sandbox or the playground saying
whoever smelt it dealt it it's it's
silly and childish
and i can't believe that it actually
passes as an argument in some political
circles in the united states
so with that out of the way let's now
look at donald trump's record
because people saying oh his his friends
are black and he likes
black pizza guy herman cain or his
daughter converted to judaism
let's look at trump's public record of
actions and statements
remember during the central park five
case donald trump believed
that five black kids committed a rape
that they didn't commit
and actually spent money for an ad
claiming that the death penalty
should be reinstated specifically for
them
and trump attacked them even after they
had been exonerated
but meanwhile he had no problem with the
deal that is outgoing labor secretary
alexander acosta struck with serial
child sex assaulter jeffrey epstein
donald trump led
the birther conspiracy which questioned
whether barack obama was truly born in
the united states
on the basis of supposed irregularities
with his long-form birth certificate
this was a
racist conspiracy theory furthered and
fomented
by racist donald trump was at the head
of the pack
when it comes to that trump has been
targeted
by the justice department in the united
states for racist
housing practices against people of
color
at buildings that he owned or managed in
new york city
donald trump attacked the judge who was
presiding over a case involving trump
university
saying that because the judge is mexican
and the judge
had mexican parents because the judges
of mexican descent
they can't possibly be impartial
arbiters
of trump's case uh which is of course
completely and absolutely outrageous
trump has mocked the genocide of native
americans
in the united states donald trump
suggested that american-born
members of congress should go back to
their quote original countries which is
extraordinarily racially tinged
xenophobic language and sentiment trump
referred to poor countries
with high non-white populations as
i guess we can say it now but i won't
just do not get any of our stations in
trouble
s-hole countries this includes haiti
el salvador and african countries trump
once said
immigrants from haiti all quote have
aids and that nigerian immigrants
would quote never go back to their huts
so listen is there ever going to be
anything trump does that will convince
a racism denier that trump is racist
there isn't if something walks like a
duck though and it talks like a duck
and it smells like a duck it's probably
a duck and that's exactly what we have
here
now again some will hear me say this and
they'll say david
you're inferring trump's racism you
don't really know what's in his mind
you can't read his mind and know what's
in there well generally people say
what's on their minds
when they don't they usually say things
that make them look
better than what's in their minds not
drastically worse so we just can't be
afraid to call things what they are
especially when world leaders around the
world
are not holding back anymore nancy
pelosi called it xenophobic
british politician david lammy called it
1950s racism from the white house check
out his tweet quote
donald trump telling four ethnic
minority american congresswomen to go
back
where they originally came from 1950s
racism
straight from the white house any
british politician
fit to service prime minister would
condemn boris johnson will you
getting into internal british politics
as i told you yesterday british prime
minister theresa may called it quote
completely unacceptable
the first minister of scotland nicola
sturgeon
tweeted quote the president of the
united states telling elected
politicians
or any other americans for that matter
to go back to other countries
is not okay and diplomatic politeness
should not stop us saying so loudly and
clearly
london mayor sadiq khan said on a radio
show in the last couple of days quote
i've heard it from racists and fascists
never
from a mainstream politician here you
have the president of the usa
using that same sort of language and
canadian prime minister justin trudeau
has also denounced donald trump's
comments saying quote i think canadians
and indeed
people around the world know exactly
what i think of those comments
this is not how we do things in canada a
canadian
is a canadian is a canadian uh and
lastly belgian politician
guy verhofstadt said quote trump's
racism
is sickening so they're calling this for
what it is
we can also call it for what it is but
and here is the important but and this
is
what is not maybe being discussed as
much as it should
you need to understand when you call
this what it is
that this may be no accident but
actually part of the trump pence
re-election plan
and we should just understand that fully
i'm not saying
don't call racism racism i'm just saying
let's understand
the full scope of what's going on here
heather parton also known as digby
wrote a really good piece in salon and
she says
this is a strategy that the republican
party of 2019 actually believes will get
donald trump and mike pence reelected
and it may because there is this bigger
environment of pro-white
pro-christian nationalism that
is all part of what even if the details
sound bad right when we caging kids
sounds bad
telling americans to go back to their
original countries to some people that
sounds bad
it's painting a very favorable
right-wing nationalist picture
of the trump administration meant to get
him reelected so put it all together
right refugee camps at the border which
we would condemn as a country if they
were happening elsewhere
red meat xenophobia on twitter against
mostly american-born members of congress
who happen to be ethnic minorities
stoking fears of violent criminal aliens
while
undocumented immigrants we know commit
crime
at lower rates than american-born
citizens mike pence showing up at border
detention centers
and looking as the uh unempathetic
indifferent lunatic that he is trump
announcing that ice raids are going to
start quote
rounding up alleged criminals who simply
haven't been caught yet
we're on the left so we see this and we
imagine oh
if people simply find out that this is
what they're saying and doing they're
not going to vote for them
that's not how it works we're on the
left we don't understand
how a lot of these right-wingers see
this stuff this is a package
of so-called being tough on immigration
the tweets the child cages all of this
stuff
may well get donald trump reelected
because the right
absolutely loves the tough on
immigration image
2020 is going to be a mess partially
it's going to be a mess because of voter
suppression
partially it's going to be a mess
because of the seeding of doubt
about whether any results that show
donald trump losing can be trusted
that's already something
trump is is ginning up but it's also
going to be a mess because
trumpists will be publicly voting
for what we are seeing trump do and say
day
in and day out including the racism and
the xenophobia so the only path forward
is removal with such overwhelming voter
turnout
that even the voter suppression and the
electoral college which is stacked
against the left
and the rampant unhinged xenophobic
nationalists
cannot get trump re-elected and it's
really simple how it works
if we can't do it it's another four
years of trump that is
increasingly the way it's looking to me
i hate to say it
okay we cannot convince them to change
their minds
so the only way to get rational people
to help us win this thing is to get
non-voters who already agree with us to
vote
okay everybody talks about this election
will hinge on turnout
it will literally hinge on turnout and i
don't know how to get the turnout up
we're going to talk about that later in
the week a little bit but it's what has
to be done we don't have corporate media
on our side yesterday i told you
that much of the trump xenophobic go
back to your original country stuff
is meant to divide the left the trump
republican strategy is
throw red meat at them divide the left
make the eventual democratic nominee
toxic meanwhile
fire up his own base with xenophobic
racist uh commentary
corporate media is falling right in line
with debates about
the substance of donald trump's stupid
tweets instead of the role that they are
meant to play in influencing the
discussion
and of course keeping trump's scandals
out of the news so this is really bad
this is possibly as bad as it has been
and i hope that you'll understand what's
going on and that way you'll be working
with us and trying to effect change in
2020 and just as importantly
in 2022 in which the senate will
actually be up for grabs for democrats
it won't be in 2020.
we need to be thinking about all of
these things but in order to do it we
need to understand
exactly what it is that donald trump is
doing with this commentary
and in the end it's okay to call racism
racist
we've just got to understand the role
that it's playing in helping to get this
guy reelected
let me know what you think uh of the way
this is all fitting together i'm on
twitter
deepakman follow me on twitter at d
pacman
and follow the show on twitter at david
pakman show